[Music]
what is up Wolfgang
so I'm not sure if any of you have heard
or seen online today but apparently
there was a leaked plot for Avengers 4
now obviously there's no way to tell the
validity of this leaked plot since it is
just something I circulated online
however I will say that it is very
specific and it makes a lot of sense
again I don't know if this leaked plot
is true or not
but if it is it will give away major
spoilers about Avengers 4 so watch at
your own risk
and since we're going into the pot of
Avengers 4 there will obviously be some
spoilers about Avengers infinity Wars so
if you have not seen it this is a
spoiler alert also if you're new we are
giving a speaker giveaway all you have
to do is subscribe to my channel
subscribe to the stupendous waves
channel leave a like and drop a comment
below with your favorite superhero that
could be from Marvel DC or otherwise we
have just about a week left on it it
ends May 30th ok so let's get into the
apparent plot leaked ok so most of us
have seen this photo I believe and if
you haven't here's a link above to a
video I did on it explaining it okay so
the gadgets sort of watch like gadgets
on their arms that everybody thinks are
time travel devices are apparently
devices that Hank Pym made that enabled
the user to exit the quantum realm
during time travel we know that in the
movie ant-man and the wash they're
really going to explore the quantum room
or the Microverse as it's called in the
comics and apparently they're going to
find and bring back Janet Van Dyne who
is the wife of Hank Pym if this is true
then Janet has been stuck in the quantum
realm for many many many years and if
they managed to bring her back then she
obviously has to have a vast amount of
knowledge about the quantum realm so as
of right now everything kind of seems to
be lining up a lot of this makes sense
so far but here's where they're going to
take a different approach to the time
travel aspect of Avengers 4 so according
to this league they're going to be
traveling to an alternate reality what
mirrors their own but they're going to
be jumping through various points in
time to alter reality and ultimately
what they're doing is they're going to
be trying to make their own Infinity
Gauntlet to use against Thanos so this
is where it seems to get a little
confusing because it's not the same
reality it's not like they're just going
back in time it's a different reality so
if they do something in this other
reality it probably wouldn't affect
what's happened in their own reality now
there's already been so many different
theories about this in itself right now
a lot of people are kind of saying oh
it's going to be similar to x-men Days
of Future past but it's still pretty
confusing I don't think it's gonna be
like that what actually comes to my mind
when I hear this is the Scarlet Witch
and house of M in the house of him The
Scarlet Witch creates an alternate
reality in which she brings some people
back to life and when the alternate
reality goes away they stay alive this
is what I can see happening I can see
them doing a bunch of things in this
alternate reality but eventually really
what happens is they just get the
Infinity Gauntlet nothing affects their
current reality but they take that
Infinity Gauntlet back to their own
reality and they have the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet so apparently some of
the characters that were left alive at
the end of infinity work we're done for
a very specific purpose and that is they
know where the Infinity stones are if
you remember in infinity war where Thord
gets aboard the Milano with the
guardians of the galaxy he lists off
where most of the Infinity stones are
not to mention in thor ragnarok in the
very beginning he mentions that he went
exploring the nine realms for the
Infinity stones so he knows where just
about all of the Infinity stones are
except for the soul stone but nebula is
still alive and she knows that the soul
stone is on Vermeer so their plan for
this alternate reality is to go in it
and find all of the Infinity stones and
then go to neduvaali R and have King III
forge an Infinity Gauntlet for them to
put the Infinity stones in and use
against Thanos in their own reality this
league plot theory states that Thor
rocket and Captain Marvel are going to
be the ones that travel to neduvaali R
and it also says that Tony Stark is
going to be the one to wield the
Infinity Gauntlet it's also said that we
will see the dwarves of neduvaali R in
action before Thanos shows up and lays
waste to all of them except for
continuing with the plot leak it is said
that the Avengers and the alternate
reality will go back to the Battle of
New York from the first Avengers movie
after it ends here Loki somehow
overhears what their plan is and manages
to tell Fano somehow he is the god of
mischief
so Thanos knowing all this new
information about the Avengers thanks to
Loki acts sooner rather than later when
it comes to obtaining the Infinity
stones
The Avengers get their hands on the
space stone and the mine stone and then
they travel to get the Power Stone on
Xander but Thanos has argued there he
attacks early because of the information
he learned from Loki this leads to a
battle between the Avengers and Thanos
right there on zan dock and what Stannis
still comes out the winner and he still
gets his hand on the Power Stone
unfortunately this is where the plot
league ended but like I said this seems
to make a lot of sense and I actually
really like it because I was kind of
bummed when I heard they were gonna do a
time-travel theme in Avengers 4 because
I didn't want them to go that route but
this way they're kind of going that
route without actually going that route
and they would make a lot of sense too
because there's been characters that
have been reported to be seen on set
that died a really long time ago such as
Quicksilver so when they go to the
alternate reality and go to get the mind
stone that's in the staff obviously
Quicksilver is still alive in that
reality and maybe they can somehow take
him from one reality and drag him to
their own reality again much like what
happened in the House of M series but
that is all we have for this leak plot
was this your first time hearing it or
have you seen this online today either
way I want to know your initial reaction
to this theory could we have possibly
just discovered the plot to Avengers 4
and possibly some of the scenes or is
this just nothing again let me know in
the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video please give it a thumbs up
and a final reminder to subscribe to my
channel and join the wolf gang and be
entered in our giveaway thank you so
much for watching
wolf wolf